I try to give Jack as much credit as I
can and and for the folks that don't
know who he is I assume everybody did
that's why he's the host and founder of
The Young Turks very popular prominent
Progressive uh news and comments here on
social media used to ban MSNBC so he's a
prominent guy he's got he's got millions
of followers not popular with Armenians
no certainly not certainly not and he
doesn't want to drop that name The Young
Turks which basically is akin to saying
the Hitler Youth but yeah we have this
from CNN they say Sanders retracts
endorsement of controversial
Congressional candidate this is crazy
Bernie Sanders with Drew his endorsement
of Jank uger after pushback from
supporters over euger's previous
controversial comments as well as his
his decision not to accept endorsements
so even Bernie was like yeah we're not
gonna endorse this guy jank's got this
video that he that he's not going to
live down and I I it is it's it's a
silly video but we have to bring it up
because it matters it's from 10 years
ago I think where he talks about how if
he's uh if he was the benevolent
dictator of the world he would legalize
giving pleasure to animals